cable news has struggled to get the
American public to care as much as
they're required to about impeachment
Ukraine and Russia this might be worth
some reflection maybe other stories are
more important to people who live here
like the fact they're dying younger who
know Ford on the lawn over on CNN
there's an easier answer ordinary people
are stupid
unlike Don LeMond stupid and look he
also knows deep in his heart that Donald
Trump couldn't find Ukraine in a map if
you had the letter U and a picture of an
actual physical crane next to it he
knows that this is you know an
administration defined by ignorance of
the world and so that's partly him
playing to their base and playing to
their audience you know the the the
credulous Boomer Rube demo that backs
Donald Trump that wants to think that
that the dog Tropes a smart one in there
oh yo yo elitist for only they may lead
us nowhere Ukraine is yeah well there
are a lot of lessons you can take from
that tape which is all over the Internet
and you should play it again and again
because it tells the whole story in the
moment we're living in first and most
obviously once again the things they're
accusing you of not generally but
specifically are exactly the things
they're guilty of themselves they're
projecting they're externalizing their
own internal problems in neuroses and
laying them at your feet you're a racist
say people who attack you for your skin
color
you're an idiot says Don LaVon and that
other guy with the beard again Don Lemon
this is the man and we're not making
this up who once questioned out loud
whether a missing airliner might have
flown into a black hole what if it was
hijacking or terrorism or mechanical
failure or pilot error but what if it
was something
fully that we don't really understand a
lot of people have been asking about
that about black holes and on and on and
on they're also referencing the twilight
zone which is a very similar plot that's
what people are saying I know it's
preposterous but is it preposterous do
you think Mary
Don LeMond the man who sincerely
believes that the fruit-based
cold desert is pronounced sore bet
calling you stupid
we're joined tonight by author and
columnist mark Stein he was a
connoisseur of moments like this it's
great to see you mark so as a rube
who lives in rural America how are you
responding to this
yeah that's CNN flying the Democrats
into the black hole if you want more
Trump this is how you get more trouble
they might as well they might as well
real able that panel the the Trump
reelection committee that that's that's
what they're doing is this is the this
is actually the bipartisan establishment
condescension summed up completely sixty
three million people are credulous rubes
according to these guys by by the way
the black hole theory isn't things like
that's come by every day on CNN just an
MSNBC just the other day lawrence
O'Donnell suggested that Trump drones
soleimani as a favor to John Bolton so
that Bolton would agree not to testify
impeachment to Harvard I don't think and
you know it's not gonna stop there next
thing yeah as a faith if Bolton doesn't
go for that Trump might under drone
Justin Trudeau that's where they talk
about on CNN and MSNBC and and they're
the ones who say that the sixty three
million people are just trade ulis route
I'd be interested if hunter Biden could
find Ukraine on a map and he's made
millions of dollars from that joint also
also like Chris Cuomo a Yale graduate
did you go to you right mark look at
your I don't think a smart enough to go
to Yale are you no no I I suddenly
couldn't I be I suddenly don't have the
I mean this this is the
see of this that your your it's not a
public policy difference anymore it's
just that they're stupid it used to be
that just Republican presidents were
stupid now they're saying that tens of
millions of Americans are stupid and in
and in a democratic age that's actually
not going to help the people who advance
that theory imagine thinking that anyway
I mean it's it's a deeply uncharitable
inhumane cruel way to look at your own
country and it's it's hard to imagine
people feel that way it's like a hot mic
moment that's what's so weird it's like
they're talking in the commercial break
and they don't realize they're on air
and that's how they really think of
millions of their countrymen it's and
and and and actually his line Rick
Wilson stupid line he's a Republican
Party strategist Republican voters give
money to the Republican Party and the
Republican Party gives it to idiots like
Rick Wilson that bipartisan nonsense is
why we're where we are today
exactly man we missed you last week mark
Stein welcome back thank you hey great
to be where the attacker thank you